when I was in college I called my
parents and said I'm getting headaches
looking at the board in calculus after I
went through all the tests my doctor
told me that I had 2015 vision I just
didn't understand calculus this is how
to find the right glasses frames for
your face I'm with a man who knows
la-based glasses designer Garrett Lite
we also have a panel of extreme
stylishness to prove that you are in
fact an expert we're going to play a
little game we're gonna have you find
the right glasses for each of these guys
look and then we're gonna see what they
think of how you do that's it you ready
for that No
so let's do it it's like everything with
style the first thing you got to do is
know yourself have a look in the mirror
so the general rule is you want to go
the opposite of what your face shape is
to sort of distract from those features
oval face shape people are in luck
for the most part they'll be able to
wear round frames square frames
rectangular frames oversized you want it
to fit just on the outside of your
cheekbones which define the area how
wide or how narrow a frame should be
right black too strong color for sure I
usually like a matte black because it
doesn't have that like extra glossy pop
to it a darker tortoise on lighter skin
and the lighter Taurus and darker skin
kind of wears once again that kind of
opposite thing crystals going to be a
little hard on Ferriss because crystal
would clear like a clear yeah but
there's like pink crystal and peach
crystals so like a pure pure crystal
would look the best not fair-skinned if
you really wanted a crystal frame
balance is the best way to put it like
if you're very effect from maybe do not
such a bold color I mean I'm always a
fan of thin glasses for comfortability
especially on optical I could wear my
glasses all day and it doesn't feel like
I'm wearing glasses
and imbalances middle-school you got to
kind of consider your whole outfit in
style and when it comes to sunglasses I
look for something subtle I chose these
frames for Josh because I feel like he's
got a nice original look and speaking to
not wanting to take away from his outfit
I feel like his accessories from the
earring to the necklace kind of help
give him that pop so he doesn't need to
go too crazy here I've always found it
really difficult to find glasses that
fit my face I have a couple of go twos
that I've been wearing for years I chose
a square matte black frame for Josh
maybe it's my fault for associated like
a beach lifestyle with Josh but I just
feel like a nice square frame is
something that suits that lifestyle
occasionally I try to go big and then I
look like an idiot but I do it anyway it
looks like a hand
so with Nick he's like a bit of a
chameleon so he's really fun I wanted to
do optical because you're always seeing
him in Sun so let's take a look at how
we can get him at an optical frame we
tried a bunch on they all looked really
good on him but not everybody can do
this and I wanted to pick this frame
before that it's just like a nice little
round delicate frame but it just still
looks maybe a little more like weird
president I chose to van Buuren frame
this is probably not a frame josh is
going to be wearing like six months
everyday because it's a little more
progressive but I just felt like it'd be
a nice addition to his collection and
it's still classic it's got a g15 lens
like a really slight mirror and a
tortoise windsor rim and the lens is
flat like that's cool through the flat
base line I'm into the I'm into the base
line yeah and I understand calculus what
I'm wearing on he's just his own icon
right here
thanks guys gentlemen if you have any
questions for us or forget it leave them
in the comments subscribe to the GQ
YouTube channel and we will see you next
time thank you